samedi matin 8h30 heure locale haïti
trombe un séisme de magnitude de 7,2 ce
produit tout près de la ville de
saint-louis du sud au sud ouest de la
capitale port au prince des hôtels des
églises des maisons se sont effondrées
ravivant les pires souvenirs du
tremblement terre de 2010 qui a fait
plus de deux cent mille morts et des
milliers de sans abri
une alerte au tsunami est déclenchée
provoquant la panique les haïtiens court
pour se réfugier sur les montagnes le
gouvernement a décrété l'état d'urgence
pour un mois
gouvernement décide et mater un dégoût
et et l'état d'urgence le premier
ministre appelle la population à
demeurer solidaire et d'éviter la
panique le directeur de la protection
civile fait état de centaines de morts
dont l'ancien sénateur gabriel fortuné
les hôpitaux reçoivent les premiers
blessés il déborde voilà on est débordés
effectivement avec les blessés mais
aussi
beaucoup de traumatiser ce tour les
enfants les médecins qui à l'aide pour
des renforts il manque d'équipements
comme chez nous on a encore quelques
paquets de gaz en a que soluté mais je
pense que si on en reçoit autant de cas
ce matin dans les prochaines heures dont
nous n'aurons plus de ressources
l'approvisionnement sera difficile des
routes sont sectionnés et des bandes
criminelles les domine il ya une demande
de crève techniquement les secours de
leur pouvoir se déplacer mais même
l'accès donc au sud à partir d'un
capital pourrait être compliquée dans
les derniers jours sur une collaboration
des gangs à des gangs armés le mauvais
sort semble s'acharner sur la perle des
antilles les cicatrices du tremblement
de terre de 2010 est encore bien visible
quand l'ouragan matthews a frappé
durement l'ouest de l'île en 2016 et le
gouvernement du pays est à la dérive
à la suite de la mort cet été de son
président joël moïse froidement
assassiné par un escadron a remis le
premier ministre ariel henry est à la
tête du pays dont l'autorité est
contestée l'état aide
sonné il n'y a pas de vie en haïti il
n'y a pas de vie les gens ne peuvent pas
senti peuvent pas traverser le sud avec
quand les gangs de rue c'est pas normal
un pays à genoux dont la résilience
semble sans borne ici marie josée paquet
comme radio canada montréal